[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei bild die
richtigen fragen putins gas fließt auch
weiter und unsere milliarden fließen
ebenfalls weiter dafür während dieser
sendung zeigen wir ihnen wie viel geld
weiterhin fließt und seit kriegsbeginn
bereits geflossen ist hier unten im bild
in diesem geld zähler sehen sie die
summe der gesamten eu zahlung seit
kriegsbeginn an putin und in den
nächsten 60 minuten werden dort immer
weitere millionen dazukommen bei allen
kriegsverbrechen die bereits geschehen
sind und auch während dieser sendung
weiter geschehen gas oder gewissen wir
führen diese moral debatte hier heute
bei bild bei den richtigen fragen und
tun das mit diesen gästen nämlich hier
im studium mit ralf fücks dem grünen
darf ich sagen vordenker einem mann der
in den 68ern gegen den vietnamkrieg auf
den straßen war und jetzt auch dafür
wirbt ja auch militärisch zumindest ganz
entschlossen sich gegen putin zu
verteidigen herzlich willkommen ihnen
zugeschaltet diese spitzenpolitiker bei
uns nämlich der csu vize manfred weber
chef der konservativen im eu-parlament
ich begrüße ralf stegner den
spd-bundestagsabgeordneten und im
auswärtigen ausschuss auch ihnen
herzlich willkommen bei bild und ich
begrüße den
militärbischof katholisch der bundeswehr
franz josef oberbeck und zugeschaltet
herzlich willkommen und ganz besonders
freue ich mich an diesem tag auf
ladislav miko er ist uns zugeschaltet
direkt ausputzer herzlich willkommen bei
bild und jetzt schon einen herzlichen
dank dafür dass wir mit ihnen heute
springen können ich möchte mit ihnen
gerne anfang helmut schenke sie haben in
den vergangenen tagen ja sozusagen die
aufgabe gehabt die toten dort nach
diesen schrecklichen kriegsverbrechen
von der straße zu holen fotos zu machen
das alles zu dokumentieren
sie haben auch die zahl der leichen dort
gezählt wir sehen einige ihrer aufnahmen
die sie dort gemacht haben hier mit
schenker das sind bilder die uns schon
nicht aus dem kopf gehen warum haben sie
das gemacht warum haben sie das gemacht
[Musik]
ich wurde gebeten von unseren soldaten
dies zu dokumentieren
wenigstens zu fotografieren nur deshalb
brauche diese fotos nie bei mir im
telefon und ich hoffe wenn alles zu ende
ist werde ich diese fotos bei mir
löschen können es ist einfach die
dokumentation der verbrechen des
russlands wir haben diese bilder auch
noch mal gezeigt und sie sagen sie
brauchen diese bilder nicht aber selbst
wenn die vom handy gelöscht sind die
bleiben uns ja schon in den köpfen die
wir viele viele kilometer entfernt sind
und diese bilder nur immer wieder auch
unseren zuschauern zeigen um zu zeigen
was für schreckliche kriegsverbrechen
begangen wurden auch bei ihnen eben in
butter vor allen dingen aber was machen
sie mit all diesen bildern selbst wenn
sie sie irgendwann löschen werden von
ihrem telefon die bleiben doch im kopf
ich hoffe sehr
ich hoffe sehr dass ich das vielleicht
endlich vergessen kann
ich möchte diese bilder nicht bei mir in
erinnerung behalten das ist
schattenseiten erfüllt menschen
erschossen
verbunden sind
an den menschen
haben gegessen und wurden dabei ermordet
es sind menschen die
einfach was sie bewegt haben wir auf dem
fahrrad der jemand hat kartoffeln
geführt jemand holz alle erschossen
ich versuche mich geradezu warmen dass
es einen schrecken
schenken sie stehen jetzt
haben hunde und beine zwei tage
gesammelt
den schenke sie stehen genau dort wo man
versucht den toten nach ihrem
schrecklichen kriegsverbrechen noch ja
ein bisschen würde wieder zurückzugeben
wir haben diese bilder gesehen in den
leichensäcken wie sie dort einfach rein
geworfen wurden gestapelt wurden in
diesen langen gräben
massengräber dort auf dem friedhof
vielleicht können sie uns das einmal
zeigen verbunden mit der frage hier aus
berlin angesichts dessen was geschehen
ist glauben sie an gott an so etwas wie
gott
ich glaube an gott und jetzt glaube ich
noch mehr an gott dann nur gott hat mich
da vorbereitet was ich gerade erlebt
haben oder bei einer erschossenen
unter bombenhagel raten und es ist der
vielleicht hat er mich davor bewahrt
weil ich jetzt hier gebraucht werden
dafür was ich gerade tue
ich habe es ist geplant ich wollte es
nicht tun aber so ist es gekommen bei
uns in unserer runde ist der katholische
militärbischof der bundeswehr franz
josef oberbeck overbeck wenn sie das
hören die bilder sehen jetzt auch
aktuell mit herrn mit schenkung
sozusagen direkt auf diesem friedhof an
diesem massengräbern fangen butscher
sind was sagen sie herr schenke auch im
umgang mit all seinen bildern mit all
dem was er erleben mussten und mit
seinem satz ich glaube erst recht an
gott
das ist
zu kriegen einfach zu gelten und genau
die will ja
sehen musste auch wissen dass überhaupt
erinnerte sich die frage ob das zuletzt
ist eine ohne antwort das weiß ich aus
eigener glaubenserfahrung sozusagen über
feld und überträgt uns bisher aber kaum
sehen jesus selbst kommt ja auch durch
gewalt und was sie uns wie vielen
menschen diesen stärken bisschen näher
auf deiner seite ist denn ohne die mit
dem größten verbrechen verleiten
diesen tagen und dass uns beide
verbindet so viele sind hier dass sie
auf das bild und das beten darum was
deren ende nicht weh war auch das was
sie tun als ein zeichen dafür dass der
kasten
die möglichkeit menschlich zu kommen
hermann schenk uhr während wir darüber
sprechen dass wir auch beten für sie uns
verneigen vor ihnen sind natürlich ganz
pragmatische dinge auch gefragt bei
ihnen neben unseren waffen neben den
waffen der europäer quälen wir uns hier
in deutschland immer noch mit der
diskussion was wir eigentlich mit putins
gas machen wir quälen uns und tun uns
wahnsinnig schwer seit wochen seit
monaten da einen strich zu ziehen und zu
sagen wir müssen irgendwie ohne
auskommen wie erleben sie das in bucha
diese debatte der deutschen und das
festhalten am russischen putin gas
ich wurde und bitten
minimal immer einfach mit russland
zusammenzuarbeiten weil ihr dieses drama
balkon nicht stoppen können dann einfach
das auf ein minimum zu fahren
geld damit verdienen
dieses geld für die aufrichtung nutzen
ihnen bahn garnituren
staat zerstört es ist ein genozid der
ukraine und das läuft auf kosten und so
stellt des arztes litt dafür genießt die
ukraine zu zerstören minimal einfach
gegen eine zusammenarbeit oder einfach
sagen ohne russland
russland soll nicht sein
hersteller können sie helmut schenke
angesichts dieser worte irgendwie noch
erklären warum wir aus ihrer sicht an
dem gas von putin festhalten
zunächst mal sind des abscheulichen
kriegsverbrechen die wir da sehen wo wir
glaube ich alle die gleichen
empfindungen haben und ausdauer umgehen
muss dass diejenigen die das zu
verantworten haben auch verfolgt und
bestraft werden
die frage was man tun kann um den krieg
möglichst schnell zu stoppen und putin
zu stoppen da gehen die meinungen
sie gehen nicht auseinander in der frage
dass wir so schnell wie möglich den
fehler korrigieren müssen der
energieabhängigkeit von russland das
geschieht jetzt bei kohle und öl und so
schnell wie möglich auch beim gas wobei
ich hinzufügen möchte sanktionen sind
dafür da denjenigen zu bestrafen den man
bestrafen will das heißt spielt schon
eine rolle ob der schaden zufügt auf der
anderen seite größer ist oder ob wir
dafür sorgen dass wir selbst
der massen destabilisiert werden
struktur brücke haben das muss auch
vermieden werden aber es bleibt dabei
sollen so schnell wie möglich raus wie
schnell das geht darüber gehen die
meinungen auseinander auch von experten
aber das ist keine frage um an dem einen
moral zu sprechen kann in dem anderen
nicht den wir sind eigentlich in dem
ziel erst der krieg zwischen irgend
möglich zu beenden und zwar ins putin zu
stoppen mit allen möglichkeiten liga das
ist schon eine frage der moral oder des
schlechten gewissens herr fücks
plagt sie ein schlechtes gewissen als
deutscher ihm gegenüber hermann schenk
gegenüber dass wir so ist es ja
geschäfte waren weiter mit putin
das hat er eine lange vorgeschichte wir
stecken
jetzt in einer selbstgebauten falle das
wäre mehr als 20 jahre hinweg uns immer
tiefer in die energieabhängigkeit von
russland begeben haben und damit
gleichzeitig putins kriegskasse gefühlt
haben wir haben die aufrüstung
maßgeblich mitfinanziert das muss man so
hart sagen
jetzt gibt es zwei unterschiedliche
argumente die einen sagen weil wir so in
der in der vergangenheit diesen fehler
gemacht haben können wir ihn jetzt nicht
schnell korrigieren
und das andere argument ist deshalb
müssen wir ihn erst recht jetzt schnell
lang korrigieren und putin die
finanziellen ressourcen für die
fortsetzung des krieges entziehen die
maßgeblichen russischen exil ökonomen
sagen das ist die stärkste
wirtschaftliche waffe über die der
besten verfügt um die russische
kriegsschiff in die knie zu zwingen ich
weiß dass man in der politik nicht nur
emotional handel darf das hat robert
habeck die tage ja auch ganz pragmatisch
noch mal im tv erklärt das ist
sicherlich auch so aber nochmal in der
in dieser sendung auch wir sehen diese
argumentation und diese erzählung aus
butscher wir sehen herrn menschen ist
mir noch mal die frage erfolgs plagt sie
als deutscher in diesen momenten ein
schlechtes gewissen
ich weiß ich habe mit anderen zusammen
schon vor zwei drei wochen aufrufe
initiiert öl- und gas-embargo
sofort aus dieser mischung aus ich würde
sagen historischer verantwortung ja also
was folgt denn aus diesem deutschen nie
wieder krieg nie wieder völkermord das
findet jetzt vor unseren augen statt und
wenn man moralisch mit kant argumentiert
dann werden wir uns fragen müssen habt
ihr alles getan um das so schnell wie
möglich stoppen und die antwort ist
bisher nein
ich würde aber sagen es ist nicht nur
eine frage der moral sondern auch
unserer interessen es ist in unserem
ureigenen interesse
dass putin nicht durchkommt mit diesem
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine sonst ist
die ganze europäische sicherheits
ordnung in trümmern und wir haben wieder
das recht des stärkeren
statt der herrschaft des rechts dass die
ukraine führt auch unseren krieg ja und
deshalb müssen wir sie unterstützen so
gut wir können weber ich möchte die
frage an sie nochmal weitergeben und
möchte man diese moral aspekt gerne
bleiben auch eine woche vor ostern plagt
sie ein schlechtes gewissen er
mich bleibt mich klagt das gefühl der
ohnmacht wenn ich die bilder sehen wenn
ich die letzten fünf wochen jetzt
politik gestalten soll und darf dann
glaub mich geglaubt mich das gefühl der
ohnmacht wir schauen zu in vielen
bereichen und ich bin da aber die rede
ist was anderes herr weber ganz kurz
ohnmacht ist ja was anderes als
zuschauen macht es ja wenn man nichts
tun kann und selbst damit schenkt uhr
sagt ja ihr könnt noch was tun erfolg
sagt wir tun doch nicht alles also das
ist ja keine ohnmacht das ist ja der der
fehlende wille dann an der stelle oder
eine falsche prioritätensetzung
es ist richtig weil wir ein gegner haben
mit russland der atommacht ist deshalb
bis zunächst bei der militärischen
dimension dieses gefühl der ohnmacht da
wir dürfen nicht den den die die rote
linie überschreiten das ist wirklich zu
einer eskalation zwischen der nato und
russland kommt und auf der anderen seite
ja sie haben recht wir können noch mehr
tun ich glaube gerade dass wir als
europäer bei der fragestellung der der
aktuellen anforderungen der suhler von
der leyen war ja vor kurzem jetzt in
kiew und die ganz konkreten anfragen
gekommen sind übrigens das papier heraus
nicht in erster linie die gas frage die
wichtiges und die wir entscheiden müssen
sondern die erste frage des elends g und
die die ukraine und stellt ist waffen
waffen machen dann hat sie sich das
einfach noch mal vergegenwärtigen wir
haben jetzt in europa auch wir deutsche
müssen das sehen das land das am meisten
liefert dieser land wie island island
ist der nummer eins waffen liefern die
ukraine nicht deutschland nicht
frankreich nicht die großen jahre ja mit
ungefähr 200 millionen gegenwert an
waffen das vertiefen wir gleich noch mal
herr weber aber auch an sie die frage
herr stegner denn das ist ein großer
waffen liefern spricht manfred weber
gerade an ist estland mit dem gegenwert
von 200 millionen euro ungefähr an
waffenlieferungen gleichzeitig zahlt die
eu sie sehen es hier unten im bild auf
dem geld zähler fast 30 milliarden seit
kriegsbeginn an putin für gas und für öl
also das ist ja auch eine wahnsinnige
unwucht ihr schmücken uns mit gewaltigen
waffenlieferungen von paar millionen von
paar hundert millionen euro und
gleichzeitig fließt dieser betrag und
immer immer mehr während dieser sendung
an putin für gas und öl plagt sie in
schlechtes gewissen gegenüber der
ukraine gegenüber herrn schwenker ein
schlechtes gewissen müssen die haben
diesen krieg führen deutschland führt
den krieg nicht wir versuchen die
ukraine zu unterstützen so gut wir
können und dieses können ist natürlich
immer auch eine frage der einschätzung
die man dazu hat sie noch mal sanktionen
dienen dem zweck die andere seite zu
bestrafen und das ist so schnell wie
möglich raus aus dem gast das ist
unstrittig das werden wir auch tun die
fragen wie schnell das geht da gehen die
meinungen auseinander was die offene tv
angeht da gehen die meinungen
auseinander abgesehen davon dass es mir
waffenlieferungen liebst als öffentlich
bekannt ist will ich ausdrücklich noch
mal sagen und das was teilweise zwischen
der ukrainischen regierung der deutschen
bank telefondaten von eurer scheint
insolvenz gesprochen wird unterscheidet
sich durchaus von dem was öffentlich
also sie habe ihr seine hände mit schenk
und reines gewissen sie sagen nicht wir
hätten noch das war die entscheidende
frage die herr fuchs gerade gestellt hat
könnten wir mehr tun und sie können mit
schenker ins gesicht sagen wir tun genug
wir tun alles was wir können herrn
schenk wir können das problem ist so
formulieren doch das ist eine polemische
frage ich sage nicht wir jetzt tun das
was wir nach meiner einschätzung nach
besten kräften tun können das müssen wir
auch tun weil wir natürlich auf der
seite ukraine stehen und aggressor putin
zurück gewiesen werden muss das ja gar
keine frage bisschen angriffskriege hier
werden kriegsverbrechen begangen und
muss gestoppt werden da ist der distanz
nicht präsenz ist in der frage wie
schnell das geht nur sagen die einen
diesen anderen jenes am ende müssen
politiker das entscheiden und sich dafür
rechtfertigen
in jedem land übrigens nicht erinnern
noch mal daran die sanktionen werden wir
uns noch gemeinsam beschlossen mit
unserer verbündeten ja das ist keine
alleinige entscheidung der deutschen was
dann geschieht sondern gibt es
steuerliche erinnert übrigens der
verbündeten eine treibende kraft
innerhalb der eu herman schenkung noch
mal zu ihnen nach bouchard dort auf
diesem friedhof von gucci ihr präsident
zielinski der hat in den vergangenen
stunden gesagt er findet die deutschen
in diesem fall kühl empfinden sie diese
debatte die wir jetzt auch hier im
studio wieder für mit unseren gästen aus
der politik aus deutschland auch ihnen
gegenüber als kühl
ja das würde ich auch unser gespräch ist
es geht um nichts solange ihr spricht
und etwas ausdiskutiert im menschen
sterben in guca in rostock in beiden
kammern und anderen staaten wird
geschossen im lehrgarten
geschossen und wir sprechen nur wir
sondern ihr sprecht
erreicht einfach unterbricht alle
beziehungen gibt unsere waffen kein öl
kein gas aus russland ihr spricht ich
weiß nicht jungs in welcher welt lebt
ihr erlebt vielleicht in einen anderen
galaxien menschen
sterben und wir sprechen
entschuldigung nein sie brauchen sie
nicht entschuldigen hermann schenk ich
danke ihnen herzlich dass sie mit uns
gesprochen haben an diesem sonntag ich
danke ihnen herzlich dafür und die worte
sind in dieser runde angekommen herr
oberbeck wie können sie das aushalten
dass wir in deutschland diese stimmen
hören dort vom friedhof in butter und
dann ja eine völlig andere diskussion
führen und zu quälen mit solchen
kleinigkeiten wie hermann schenk das
natürlich empfindet in der ukraine der
das als kühl ebenfalls empfindet wie
sein staatspräsident selensky
ich hatte in der letzten woche eine
diskussion auch nach dem krieg wenn die
ukraine hoffentlich weiterhin bestand
haben kann die eu aufgenommen werden
musste wurden ähnliche argumente
geliefert was alles noch zu bedenken
jetzt ich habe dann einfach geantwortet
die menschen halten unsere freiheit
deren kopf und auf unsere sicherheit die
von diensten wie sehen uns räte
studierende ist das unerträglich und ihr
wisst schon lange so prinz nicht erst
nur in der ukraine das war auch schon
afghanistan syrien sollen dem wagen und
worüber alle schrecklichen dinge
geschehen für uns ist in der tat der
rote punkt liegt einer zwischen
gewinnerin verantworten und den
auszusprechen ich glaube ich jetzt
angesagt war eine ganz
selbstverständliche wurst solidarität
mit den opfern dann können wir dazu
gehören auch in denen wir gerade
gesprochen wenn ihn und ich muss jetzt
sehen wir sagen dass mir das manchmal
als bischof schon fast zu viel wird
angesichts auch übrigens der viele
menschen mittlerweile ja warum habt ihr
die flüchtlinge hier ist zuhause von
meiner haut filmsprache diemelsee die
kinder mit ihren versteckten augen sie
kennen aber auch viele andere auf ich
hab dir muss ich schon sagen dass ich
ein schlechtes gewissen deswegen haben
wir zu viert das gewicht nicht der ort
in der mitte seines herzens wo es darum
geht das jetzt punkten und was fragt was
ist böse ich glaube das kann an dieser
stelle wirklich vor einer solchen
entscheidung stehen übrigens hoffen wir
das öfter fortschritte in dem sinn der
herren sich das überhaupt
und jetzt holen 1
ja klar mich wirklich bereich solchen
gesichtspunkten und wir stehen ja aber
auch wenn er stegner das vielleicht als
polemisch empfunden tatsächlich von der
frage wollen wir dürfen wir weiter
geschäfte mit einem kriegsverbrecher
machen mit einem mann der den der
us-präsident als kriegsverbrecher
bezeichnet hat den unser kanzler so
bezeichnet hat also dürfen wir mit
diesem mann geschäfte machen was sagt
die kirche die katholische
ich möchte dir gesagt erst mal
nicht tun als der papst hat mehr klar
das zweite ist allerdings auch wir
brauchen daher eine antwort natürlich
hier vor ort und insofern kann ich die
bedenken der farbe benannten verstehen
wir gehen mensch umwelt und ich habe
keine energie mehr retten werden die
arbeitsplätze fehlen wenn normal
altersversorgung ganz schwierig wird das
gibt kein verhältnis und zu der not
vital nur für jene sehen eine frage die
noch gar nicht wissen die frage nach
unterstützung all dessen was dem krieg
beendet ich möchte nur innerhalb diese
spannung hinweisen da stehen wir auch
nicht herauskommen wenn ich bei uns zum
beispiel mit vielen menschen spielen
habe ich davon essen also im hochgebet
denke es gibt viele armes gibt werden
sofort von den folgen einer also im
dramatischen wichtigen vielleicht aber
auch sogleich schwierige
offen wären das heißt das für uns im
alltag benutzen kann wissen ist eine
volle solidarität e bike oder den osmo
etwas zu geben dann wird es dazu für uns
hier
steht er doch mal an sie zurück sie
haben auch dafür geworben im bundestag
die impfpflicht zu einer gewissensfrage
zu machen das war ganz klar für sie und
für den kanzler eine gewissensfrage und
jetzt ist es dass diese riesige diese
gewaltige frage für sie keine
gewissensfrage ob wir von einem
kriegsverbrecher weiter gas und öl
kaufen dürfen putin ist ein
kriegsverbrecher das habe ich selbst
gesagt ich will gern zu dem punkt mit
dem kühlen was da ich lässt das
überhaupt nicht unbeteiligt ist in dem
krieg menschen sterben müssen zerstörung
stattfindet vertreibung stattfindet
flucht junge menschen sterben müssen
alte menschen soldaten die sich was
anderes vorgestellt haben dass der kälte
angst und traumatisierung herrscht und
wenn wir darüber reden wie man diesen
krieg am schnellsten beenden kann dann
ist das für mich ein gedanke da für
dieses leiden zu beenden ich empfinde es
als wenn manche debatten nur noch an der
militär logik geführt werden wenn wir
inzwischen dabei sind gar nicht mehr
darüber zu sprechen dass die waffen
dienen den krieg so schnell wie möglich
zu beenden sondern dass sie dienen einen
auf wochen und monate angelegten krieg
sozusagen zu verschenken an der
gradmesser
das hat mit kühle gar nichts zu tun
sondern ist das gegenteil davon gilt den
menschen die zu leiden haben unter krieg
wie ist das schlimmste was es gibt und
wir wissen es aus anderen ligen aus
afghanistan aus syrien aus anderen
kosten irak das hier länger dauern umso
mehr menschen standarten sich sie planen
sind vielen jahren mit der frage ob ich
gerne einmal deutlich gesagt weil ich
mich auch nicht in die rhone drängen
lassen möchte von ihnen zu sagen wir
sehen das kühle ist hat er nichts mit
gewissen zu tun sondern wir haben ganz
viele emotionen spielen dabei eine rolle
und jeder muss das vertreten was dafür
warum sich das verstehen und regner sie
plagen sich mehr mit der frage ob die
deutschen waffenlieferungen diese
kleinen lieferungen die bisher passiert
sind ob die tatsächlich okay sind das
belastet ihr gewissen mehr als die frage
ob wir in dem kriegsverbrecher weiter
gas verkaufen entschuldigen sie bitte
sie formulieren es wieder hin da ganz
anders gesagt hab ich mal einfach sehen
dass täglich menschen sterben müssen
dass der krieg fortgesetzt wird das
hängt jetzt friert das wie man das am
schnellsten beenden kann das ist die
frage die ich mir stelle und da gehen
die meinungen auseinander das sollten
wir uns nicht wechselseitig die moral
absprechen sondern das miteinander
besprechen können und es geht nicht nur
um die deutschen waffen die von liebe
und größer sind als sie das darstellen
ich sage das noch mal sondern es geht
darum ob den krieg zu verlängern viele
wochen und monaten womöglich noch diesen
effekt zu haben fügt ob das wirklich die
richtige antwort sein kann und ob es
nicht andere wege gehen muss das
beschäftigt das ist ja nun überhaupt
nichts zu tun sondern im gegenteil mit
empathie für die menschen die das
aushalten müssen sind nämlich nicht wie
er hier die wir diese diskussion führen
sondern die dort vor ort sind erfolgs
steckt ja das was wir jetzt gerade
gesagt haben wer die konsequenz zu sagen
die ukraine sollen kapitulieren daran
ist der krieg morgen zu ende soll auf
der soll noch die ukraine kapitulieren
naja es recht so also fühlen sie wenn
das ihre logik ist ja ich war letzte
woche zusammen mit marieluise beck in
kiew wir haben mit parlamentariern
gesprochen mit regierungsmitgliedern mit
intellektuellen mit ngo leuten und die
botschaft war unisono ihr werdet nicht
entscheiden können ob wir kämpfen oder
nicht wir wer habe ich auch nicht gerade
unabhängigkeit unseres landes kämpfen
aber ihr aber nicht getan aber ihr könnt
mit entscheiden wie viele opfer wir noch
bringen müssen und wie lange dieser
krieg dauert und das hängt erstens daran
ob er uns die waffen liefert damit wir
in der lage sind uns gegen russland zu
behaupten
und zweitens daran ob er
russland die finanziellen ressourcen für
diesen krieg entzieht das ist unsere
verantwortung ist das was wir
beeinflussen können ich sage nochmal ich
habe mit keinem wort gesagt dass die
ukraine kapitulieren soll oder überhaupt
dass wir uns anpassen sollen das zu
entscheiden dass dies ist die
entscheidende ukraine selbst was sie tut
was sie verhandeln das ist nicht unsere
entscheidung sondern ich habe mich aus
sich mit der frage beschäftigt was die
folge ist wenn der krieg immer länger
dort wo wir ja inzwischen sind und ich
habe sehr viel empathie für diejenigen
die noch zu leiden haben sind nicht wie
er diese diskussion jetzt zu führen das
ist das was mich in der tat klagt was
der richtige weg ist und das sind auch
unterschiedliche meinungen möglich
darüber wird ja auch diskutiert
inzwischen das wissen sie auch herr
fuchs gibt es ja auch forderung
offensivwaffen einzusetzen gibt
forderung
flugverbotszonen über durch die nato
kontrollieren zu lassen vieles andere
mehr was sie aus guten gründen nicht tun
dass die ja auch in offenen bieber
benannt worden weiß nicht auf die gründe
sind momentan aber nicht verstehen dass
die grünen hat sich das anders wird aber
das diskutieren wir also nur alleine
verzeihen sie herr bischof und zu beten
und zu hoffen dass der krieg bald vorbei
ist dadurch wird es vermutlich nicht
passieren herr weber deswegen lassen sie
uns zunächst bevor wir über die
waffenlieferung sprechen noch mal gas
und öl abschließen also das war ja ganz
klar in den schenker hat ja gar nicht
gesagt und das muss man sich mal
vorstellen er steht auf dem friedhof in
butter vor diesem massengräbern und er
sagt noch nicht mal in diesem moment
völlig naiv schaltet sofort alles ab
sondern er bittet höflich darum die gas-
und öllieferungen schnellstmöglich zu
minimieren zu minimieren sagte er und
das sind seiner jetzigen situation also
was herr weber kommt jetzt in dieser
woche morgen wird wieder beraten auf eu
ebene kommt da zumindest der öl stoppt
oder ein ganz klarer fahrplan in den öl
stoppt
das liegt der europäische ebene und den
mitgliedstaaten der europäischen union
ja was sagen sich die sanktionen weil
wir sagen nur geschlossen werden können
wenn sie einstimmig von allen 27 staaten
auf den weg gebracht werden ich
persönlich bin der meinung dass wir
einen sofortigen einen sofortigen kohle
und öl stoppt brauchen mit öl verdient
übrigens putin am meisten wenn man sich
die gewinnmargen anschaut und öl ließe
sich auch relativ einfach auf den
weltmärkten kompensieren mit anderen
lieferketten egal wann man mit der
pipeline
matic sonderproblem aber bei öl und
kohle kohle können wir schneller steigt
gehen sofort aussteigen und das ist die
klare position ich darf in den übrigen
rückmeldung aus der europäischen debatte
geben werden letzte woche im
europäischen parlament von frei
gewählten abgeordneten aus ganz europa
eine abstimmung zu einer resolution das
ist exakt eingesetztes gemacht wird weil
die staaten entscheiden aber es gibt ein
gefühl über die stimmungslage und selbst
im europäischen parlament in der breiten
mehrheit haben wir über 80 prozent der
abgeordneten gesagt haben jetzt sofort
ihr größtes verständnis lauda in europa
in dieser in dieser debatte herr weber
ihr kollege liberale guy verhofstadt der
ist ja quasi auf deutschland losgegangen
er hat einen wutanfall bekommen in
dieser parlamentsrede der hat massiv
geschimpft auf deutschland er hat vor
allen dingen gesagt die sanktionen so
stufenweise das ist dieser auftritt so
er über deutschland auf deutschland
schimpft und erklärt warum das nicht
funktioniert sich den sanktionen aktuell
dass die nämlich den diktator in moskau
überhaupt nicht beeindrucken weil das
heißt keine demokratie ist diese
stufenweise weitere eskalation an sagt
zu uns die hat nichts gebracht dazu
haben wir eine insa umfrage an diesem
wochenende durchgeführt und haben unsere
zuschauer einmal gefragt glauben sie
dass die sanktionen aktuell greifen dass
die den mann in moskau im kreml aktuell
beeinflussen dass die wirkung entfalten
und die mehrheit der deutschen sagt
glauben wir nicht dass glauben wir
aktuell nicht dass die aktuell
bestehenden sanktionen tatsächlich
wirken deswegen noch mal herr stegner
das ist die umfrage dazu also knapp 70
prozent sagen nee das kommt bei putin
noch gar nicht an das bringt doch gar
nicht sie sind gar nicht wirksam die eu
sanktionen jetzt sagt manfred weber
gerade herr stegner sofortiger stopp ist
dass mit ihnen zu machen ist das mit der
spd zu machen und mit dem kanzler zu
machen glaube schon dass das eine
möglichkeit ist weil der weber ja recht
hat dass der putin ob sich damit geld
verdienen das sind leichter zu
substituieren und was die sanktions
wirkung angeht glaube ich kann man
umfragen dazu machen entscheiden ist es
die alliierten gemeinsam versucht haben
die schärfsten möglichen sanktionen
verhängen dies bisher jemals gegeben hat
und das ist unser zielgerichtet zu tun
anders als früher dass man jetzt nicht
sofort weg aber nach allem was ich weiß
jedenfalls gibt es da keinen großen
dissens darüber soll im gegenteil es
wird einvernehmlich farben redet kann es
nicht nur von den deutschen
nicht einer der uns öffentlich
beschimpft so zu sagen hat hinter
verschlossenen türen vereinbart genau
das mit das ist so das will ich gar
nicht beklagen aber der kern ist dass
wir die dinge immer nur gemeinsam machen
können das passiert auch mit dem ziel
dass putin regime zu treffen und zwar
möglich stärker zu treffen als man
selbst wobei deutschland ohnehin
wahrscheinlich mit die größten schäden
wird erhält müssen das macht aber
insofern nichts weil ich sagen muss
natürlich hat die bevölkerung eine
ungleich mehr zu leiden als wir das zu
tun wir müssen tun was wir können und
das muss aber verantwortlich entschieden
werden denn enthalten sind sie teilweise
oder in dieser sendung wir uns dann
vorgehalten wird wenn das nicht bedacht
also seine grenzen kommen sollen sie als
gehören einsendung dass emotionen das
eine ist ein verantwortliches handeln
das kühler kopf und heißt es herr
arbeitest du ja aber man kann ja jetzt
auch nicht dass eine nur als emotionen
wie blöde gefühle und so weiter abtun
und ich hab ich nicht gesprochen
entschuldigt was kann man ja auch nicht
jeder möchte einmal verstehen ob sie
jetzt persönlich führen sofortigen stopp
sind dass das auf eu ebene entschieden
wird und so weiter das ist ja völlig
klar und dass deutschland da betreibende
kraft sein kann das wissen wir auch aber
nicht die alleinige also sind sie dafür
dass das morgen der ersten in
deutschland würde das mit sicherheit
nicht blockieren wenn das bei kohle und
öl so passiert bei gas ist es
komplizierter aber auch da müssen wir so
schnell wie möglich aus das ist gar
keinen dissenz
blockiert haben ja genug schon in den
vergangenen wochen und monaten heraus
sagen sie in wir wenn wir sprechen über
die ganzen ja meinung gegenüber putin
die sich ja relativ plötzlich geändert
haben ich habe mich in putin gehört das
ist ja so ein satz der im moment immer
öfter gesagt wird unter anderem vom
bundespräsidenten wohl gar nicht klar es
hat er sich wirklich geehrt oder hat er
ihn nicht viel mehr über monate und
jahre gedeckt dort mit seiner politik
auch es gibt drei audienzen in den
vergangenen jahren von putin beim papst
hat sich auch der papst geirrt in putin
herr oberbeck
soweit ich weiß hat der platz immer sehr
realistisch dass die machtposition des
russischen präsidenten wir schauen
darauf sein tun erst recht seit 2014 und
gar nichts von der krim ich kann von mir
aus muss sagen dass ich sehr gar nicht
kann das sparen wir als es jetzt wieder
so los ich glaube auch dass die meisten
ebenfalls in rom und im vatikan selbst
das recht dass er sich dann gewesen
jedenfalls dass wir auch konkret und
unseren glauben
aber auch univision und verwaltet
gewusst haben
verbrecher ist schon also das würde ja
jetzt vermutlich nicht realistisch seine
audienz für den kriegsverbrecher aber es
gibt ja genau diese audienzen nämlich 3
also das heißt wenn man das alles vorher
gesehen hätte wenn man sich nicht geirrt
hätten hätte man ja vermutlich ihn nicht
den vatikan eingeladen oder sehe ich das
falsch
denn die stimme dafür aber eine andere
rolle hinblick auf erlöse von politik
ich meine dass kinder diese rücksicht
der papst hat mit vielen menschen
spricht und in dem man moralisch große
fragen als haben muss das geht eben auch
jetzt hier in zwickau vom russischen
präsidenten und das werk wird dabei auf
grund seiner gespräche mit dem
patriarchen von moskau
ja ja genau die richtige person ist man
machthaber in diesem sinn aber jemand
der so etwas unglaubliches das ist das
nicht versteht und sehen sie das auf
viele fragen die jungen haben sich
übrigens auch weiß aber wenn der vatikan
rolle ist gegenwärtig bindfäden dient
dann muss ich wenigstens die gespräche
option mit einem jetzt werde der papst
habe wulffs gesprächen ich würde da
haben als vor einiger zeit
aber sollte er dann nicht jetzt nach
kiel fahren zur domina lenski ihm ja
ganz bewusst den rücken stärken auch
dort in dieser stadt überhaupt präsent
sein sollte er möglicherweise auch nach
moskau zu putin wieder reisen um ihn mit
seinem starken stimmengewicht
möglicherweise eben zum frieden zu
bewegen zum stopp dieses angriffskrieges
wenn das glück wurde das duo mit glaube
dass mich erhoben am anfang war der sehr
zurückhalten um solcherart und nach
gipfel unternehmen jetzt auf der
rückreise vom alter wo ist noch bis
sonntag bewegen weshalb ich sagt dass
sie mit es darüber nachdenken und sind
in politischen fragen moskau selbst ist
derzeit noch nicht gewesen noch keiner
seiner vorgänger und vorgesehen ist das
eine angelegenheit die nur dass dieser
sport zahlen auf die ökumene mit sie
sehen wie schwierig die comen ist das
werde ist nicht dabei sehr entsetzt
alles ja auch immer wieder leute gibt
die gläubig den weg aber die das telefon
unterstützen was die kosten voll
verstehen und auch fenster und färbten
verurteilung von der im häufig zumindest
dadurch dass der park mehrere seiner
kardinäle schon geschickt hat ist man
erst geschehen wenn noch mehrere sehen
und erweckten vor nicht hatten dies
bewirkt was möglich ist wichtig es
besteht ja auch immer die vielleicht
naive hoffnung dass dann in den monat in
den momenten nicht so heftig oder am
besten gar nicht bombardiert wird das in
dem moment neben keine raketen fliegen
denen der papst oder eigentlich ein eu
staats und regierungschef dort ist wir
haben die bilder von grace jones nahmen
wochenende gesehen dem britischen
premier der durch durch die stadt
gelaufen ist was für ein starkes zeichen
dort gemeinsam mit flottem ihr selensky
herr stegner wenn sie diese bilder
gesehen haben dort aus kiew von boris
johnson hätten sie sich ein bisschen
gewünscht das wäre stolz gewesen
oder scholz nicht besonders dazu neigt
das öffentliche bild in den vordergrund
zu rücken sondern es sehr besonnener
telefoniert sehr viel mit insolvenz geht
da versucht alles zu unternehmen was wir
tun können ukraine zu unterstützen das
finde ich dann persönlich noch wichtiger
nicht als den teil den man jetzt sehen
kann durch solche bilder und im übrigen
teil von mir da gar keine ratschläge
sondern das entscheidet er selbst und
sowas wird ja auch nicht voran die
können nichts daran findet dann statt
ist schon reise gewesen herr fücks von
von boris johnson blöde jolie ist nicht
genug es hat ja was mitgebracht nämlich
die zusage dass großbritannien 120
panzerfahrzeuge schicken wird und was in
der bisherigen diskussion keine rolle
gespielt hat auch anti schiffs raketen
weil ja die ukraine auch angegriffen
wird vom schwarzen meer oder sa ist in
höchster gefahr und zweitens ist das ein
signal dass solidarität es gehört
übrigens ich war ja dort letzte woche da
wurde und den vor ort noch gekämpft
inzwischen braucht man nicht mehr
besonders viel mut um nach kiew zu gehen
es ist relativ ruhig dort man braucht
aber viel mut wenn man mit leeren händen
dorthin geht und das ist ein bisschen
das problem der deutschen politik herr
stegner das bild der ukraine über uns
ist ein ganz anderes als das was sie
hier zeichnen natürlich verstehen die
dass wir im vergleich zu den letzten 20
jahren uns in den letzten fünf wochen
ziemlich bewegt haben aber das bild ist
immer noch zu langsam zu wenig also ihr
nicht nur was das im auge angeht sondern
auch was waffenlieferungen angeht ich
meine jetzt wieder dieser zirkus um die
lieferung von mardern und gepard also
schützenpanzern aus den beständen sagen
der bundeswehr dir dann ersetzt werden
von der industrie seit wochen liegen
solche listen anforderungsliste der
ukraine im verteidigungsministerium hier
verzögern wir geben keine klare antwort
es wir ermitteln immer noch den eindruck
als wäre die dringlichkeit die dramatik
dieses krieges überhaupt nicht bei uns
angekommen sie haben sie ja stehen
verhinderungs verzögerungs kanzler einer
verzögerung des verteidigungsministerium
den erfolg sagt ja das wäre keine show
reise der kanzler könnte nach kiew
reisen und halt was mitbringen man muss
die meinung von hans fuchs ja nicht
teilen und im übrigen auch nicht die
öffentliche debatte ich weiß aus
verschiedenen quellen zum beispiel weil
man mit einem schutzraum wir einsehen
kann welche waffen geliefert worden sind
weil ihr berichtet bekommen wie die
gespräche mit der ukrainischen regierung
sind von diesen ganz anders als das was
man in der öffentlichen debatte doch
die haben immer noch
das mag in der natur der sache liegen
und noch mal die frage wie der krieg am
schnellsten beendet werden kann das ist
die frage die uns am start ja aber und
alle haben sie die behauptung lieber
deutschland erhoben werden aber stimmen
mit der realität nicht überein will das
noch mal ausdrücklich sagen aber man ist
ja gehindert an bestimmten stellen das
widerlegen zu können das muss man das
ertragen
nicht so viel zu tun der eindruck
entsteht dass die waffenlieferungen aus
deutschland ausgerechnet und nur aus
deutschland so geheim ist dass sie noch
nicht mal die ukraine erkennen und der
eindruck entsteht das haben sie auch in
der sendung gesagt herr stegner dass sie
bestimmte waffen gar nicht liefern
wollen weil das eben für sie offensiv
waffen sind in dieser zeit also sind sie
für lieferung von panzern beispielsweise
jetzt ein putin gegen putin die
fachleute sagen dass die panzer zum
beispiel wenn man sie einsetzen wollte
wochen und monate brauchen würden bis
man die einsetzen könnte ich würden
momentan gar nichts helfen und darüber
streiten ich bin kein militär fachmann
darüber wird gestritten das hat aber mit
moralischer mannschaft position nichts
zu tun ich habe vorhin schon darauf
hingewiesen dass die ukraine sich
verständlicherweise auch den gewünscht
die nato aus guten gründen nichts machen
kann weil sie nicht möchte dass die nato
kriegsteilnehmer wird da gibt es auch
unterschiedliche meinungen verstehe und
respektiere das alles aber am ende muss
die müssen ja wir verantworten was wir
tun können harry barr ist was wir tun
können das tun wir mit aller kraft
unabhängig von dem wie die öffentliche
debatte darüber ist schwachsinn ruf
gerade ralf fücks rein herr weber ich
will ja dass mussa vertreten wenn es ein
gutes argument ich will will sie einmal
da zu hören der stegner sagt wir tun
viel mehr als öffentlich bekannt ist
also sind sie einfach nicht ausreichend
informiert an der stelle
wenn wir stehen dazu spürt man genau das
was leider gottes die bundesregierung
ganz generell ausstrahlt nämlich eben
abwarten
aufschiebend bremser zu sein gerade bei
der energiefrage wenn ich das noch mal
in erinnerung rufen darf aber der
gestiegene jetzt sich für kohle und öl
stoppt ausgesprochen die bundesregierung
hingegen auf europäischer ebene den
kohle stopp der wirklich marginal ist
wirklich nur vier milliarden jedes jahr
aus das gas aus also im wert von 4
milliarden aus russland der würde noch
mehr um einen monat verschoben bis vier
monate müssen wir jetzt warten bis der
krone stopp überhaupt argumentieren
aktiviert wird das gibt bundesregierung
bremst an allen stellen ist war bei den
waffen so zunächst wurde ein schutzhelm
geliefert das war bei schrift so man hat
ewig gebraucht bis man das rift
aktiviert hat noch heute ist es nicht
voll aktiviert und bei der bei der
jetzigen situation ist es das gleiche
bei den energielieferungen deshalb war
es klar adressieren und die möchte ich
schon auch ich schätze ihn mit seinen
aussagen sehr weil ich bei der
argumentation nie wieder sehr nah an
seiner seite bin wir deutsche haben eine
besondere verantwortung in diesen in
diesem konflikt das letzte mal als cache
bombardiert war waren es deutsche
soldaten die bombardiert haben deswegen
haben wir besondere verantwortung aber
man muss auch daran erinnern dass auch
grünen mitregiert wir haben eine rot
grün gelbe regierung in berlin warum
deshalb in es nicht gelingt dass diese
regierung jetzt durchmarschiert das hört
der gleichheit gelernt nun ins bild dass
ich nicht erklären europäisches event
seiner art zu den grünen noch rein
reicht so dass er auch robert habeck und
annalena baerbock überzeugt bekommt ihr
mal eine ganz kurze pause und streiten
daniel weber stegner vor allen dingen
weiter über deutsche waffenlieferungen
bremst die regierung dort die
bundesregierung ja oder nein das nach
der kurzen pause
[Musik]
zurück bei bild die richtigen fragen an
ralf fücks an manfred weber an den
katholischen militärbischof franz josef
overbeck und dann sie herr stegner wir
sprechen hier über weitere deutsche
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine sind
sie der überzeugung dass die helfen dass
die ein krieg zu gunsten der ukraine
entscheiden könnten
wir haben wir zehn soldaten bestehen
habe also verzeihung das argument vor
wochen war ja das ist wenn möglichst
viele waffen geliefert werden der krieg
möglichst schnell beendet werden könnte
jetzt hat sich das argument veränderten
jetzt heißt es wird der krieg wird
wochen und monaten noch dauern und es
ging darum mit waffenlieferung dafür zu
sorgen ist eine verhandlungsposition
erreicht werden kann die günstiger ist
und die putin gefahrlos tisch hängt das
sind ja zwei ganz verschiedene dinge ich
habe da eine gewisse skepsis dass das
tatsächlich so es denn auch erstaunt
darüber dass die meisten debatten fast
nur noch sozusagen militärische logik
geführt werden die alternative dazu ist
ja nicht nichts tun sondern wir haben
einerseits die sanktionen über die wir
sprechen wir haben andererseits das
thema der energieunabhängigkeit wo wir
gerade gesagt wir müssen so schnell wie
möglich davon weg und die
gesprächskanäle auch und was die
deutschen davon halten weil sie umfragen
zitieren zitiert dann wenn man jetzt den
eindruck hat wie das betrachtet wird was
olaf scholz gemeinsam mit annalena
baerbock macht habe ich durchaus den
eindruck dass die deutschen froh sind
dass ein ganzer abend jemand sitzt er
das sehr besonnen macht im
schulterschluss mit dem französischen
präsidenten
gemeinsam mit den verbündeten in den usa
und eben nicht als oder oder herr merz
die wilde interviews zu dem thema geben
hier ist das glaube ich schon etwas
anderes sind dass man glaube ich schon
dass die besondere abwägung der richtige
weg ist den wir da schon in ihren
verteidigungsminister noch das ganz kurz
herr stegner sagt ja die mittel der
bundeswehr sind da im grunde auch
erschöpft man sei jetzt an der grenze
sozusagen dessen was man aus bundeswehr
ryanair ausliefern kann an die ukraine
geschmack mag schwer glauben bei 5.000
helm bei flugabwehrraketen und selbst
wenn sie sagen da ist noch viel mehr
geliefert worden als wir ja alle wissen
es ist schwer vorstellbar dass wir da an
der grenze sind dessen was möglich wäre
immerhin ist es ja so dass wir aus guten
gründen das sondervermögen bekommen
werden dass die bundeswehr wieder in der
lage versetzt dass sie zur
landesverteidigung und auch zur
bündnisverteidigung wieder besser
konstant ist als sie das zurzeit ist und
zum zweiten hat die bundesregierung ja
auch zugestimmt dass es direkte
lieferung geben kann von der deutschen
industrie die dann genehmigt werden es
geht keineswegs nur darum aus den
beständen etwas zur verfügung zu stellen
insofern ist es eine richtige
beschreibung aber nochmal das ausmaß
dessen was geliefert worden ist und dass
darüber nicht erzählt wird das ist ein
unterschied also recht wissen all
diejenigen die damit befasst sind der
gegner sagt ist es richtig das stimmt
man sei dort also dass das zitat ja von
frau lamprecht man sei dort im grunde
habe die mittel erschöpft erfolgs halten
sie das für realistisch oder redet man
sich da jetzt raus ich wusste was zu
einem zwischenruf sagen dass mir nur
schwachsinn tut mir leid aber das kommt
aus
seiner wahrnehmung ja dass wir immer
noch nicht richtig realisiert haben was
da in der ukraine passiert und was da
auch für uns und für europa auf dem
gerät wir die deutsche politik die
überwiegende der cannes sieger über die
verteidiger einen ministerin der
koalition ich würde sagen als nach allem
was ich weiß
machen gerade die grünen minister habe
und annalena baerbock richtig druck was
war für sie die schon geht kann ich
meine habe ich war ja noch vor der wahl
in der ukraine hat sich das angebot kam
zurück mit der forderung nach
waffenlieferungen wurde dafür verprügelt
er auch von olaf streubig übrigen vor
allen dingen von den grünen sei teil der
gruppe auch das doch was sie sagen wir
uns noch nicht verstanden hat sich nicht
verstärkt die grünen haben es verstanden
die grünen minister aber der kanzler hat
es noch nicht fertig ist sehe schon so
dass es bei olaf scholz einen
widerspruch gibt zwischen der
zeitenwende rede die er im bundestag
gehalten hat die ein bisschen nach
churchill klang und der zögerlichen
politik die er seitdem sank betreibt das
ist ja auch eine frage der öffentlichen
kommunikation an die eigene gesellschaft
den deutschen zu erklären was finde da
gegenwärtig in der ukraine statt ist ein
vernichtungslager worte sehr stegner
diese zeitenwende da folgten würde ich
nicht an aber es ist immer noch nicht
wirklich konsequent in der politik
angekommen ja und wir tun immer noch zu
wenig angesichts der dramatik der
entwicklung in der ukraine
die hat keine zeit ja die infrastruktur
wird zerstört die haben bereits mehr als
zehn millionen flüchtlinge über vier
millionen sind außer landes sie
verlieren natürlich täglich auch waffen
im krieg gegen die russen die bereiten
gerade eine große neue offensive vor im
osten und süden der ukraine das wird
eine materialschlacht ja dein wir nicht
liefern blutet die ukraine herr stegner
jetzt bei der materialschlacht halt wir
haben schon vier geliefert auch viel
mehr als sie und ich wissen und jetzt
können wir ja nicht in so eine
endlosschleife davon material schlaf
reinkommen ist die argumentation von
herrn stegner will mich kontinuierlich
liefern verluste ersetzen und die
ukraine auch in die lage versetzen
russland auf distanz zu bekämpfen herr
stegner weil wir sie gar nicht gehört
haben noch einmal dazwischen gerne ja
ich wir können eben nicht gleichzeitig
reden erfolgs der fluss hat ja gerade
das bestätigt was ich vorhin gesagt habe
dass es gar nicht mehr um die frage geht
wie mir gestellt zu werden das ist das
argument weil jetzt geht es darum ein
krieg über längere zeit zu führen mit
mit mehr waffen damit die
ausgangsposition anderen wird das halte
ich für schwierig aber noch mal die
behauptung es gebe darüber differenzen
in der bundesregierung ist falsch es
gibt ein gemeinsames handeln des
bundeskanzlers mit der außenminister
über seine vortrefflichen job macht nach
meiner einschätzung um zu kapieren was
dort stattfinden das ist glaube ich
nicht das problem ist das wird sehr wohl
kapiert die frage wie man das am
schnellsten den krieg wenn damit das
nicht passiert was erfolgs schildert
darüber ist die wir die diskussion
gesetzt und nur darüber wird jetzt
schauen darf ich erlebe aber stegner und
erlebe aber dass die argumente moralisch
diskreditiert werden weil man sagt hier
einen kapieren dass die anderen sind
aber relativ festen was rundfunk ist
aber aber herr stegner das machen machen
sie doch auch in dem sie sagen jeder
zeit alle diskussionen die in die andere
richtung laufen sind sofort sind sofort
reine militär diskussion so haben sie
sind sie ja in dieser diskussion ja auch
aufgetreten vielleicht herr weber kurz
dazwischen sie sagen oder die debatte
ist panzer gegen putin an dieser stelle
die argumentation von herrn stegner
haben sie klar gehört von herrn fuchs
auch wo stehen sie herr weber also
panzerlieferungen jetzt selbst wenn wir
davor stehen von der militär von der vor
der materialschlacht vor einem jahr
lange langfristigen krieg natürlich
wochen wochen wochen das ist das einzige
was zielinski es derzeit wirklich
inständig bittet rum und deswegen müssen
wir jetzt waffen liefern und man muss
mal klar definieren was ist denn das
ziel dieser sondern selbst unserer sicht
beim entstehen hört mal raus es ging nur
darum schnell wie mögliche zufrieden zu
sie zu schaffen natürlich wollen wir
alle so schnell wie möglich erreichen
das sehe ich will ich will in diesem
ziel dass putin nicht gewinnt
publizistik krieg nicht gewinnen und
deshalb müssen wir alles tun um der
ukraine jetzt unter die arme zu greifen
die tschechen liefern jetzt panzer wir
haben aus der slowakei heraus
flugabwehrraketen weil wir europäer eben
nicht bereits in einem flugzeug zu bauen
machen dass die ukraine selbst aber
dafür brauchen sie waffen und deswegen
gibt es für mich überhaupt keine frage
jetzt in großem umfang waffen liefern
auch ein mäßiges grenze für unsere pr in
bis zu eigenen verteidigungsfähigkeiten
müssen wir jetzt durch ganz oben
angreifen und das hauptargument dabei
ist dieser krieg ist eben nicht ein
russisch ukrainische krieg diese kritik
russlands gegen uns alle ganz ganz runde
also militärischer sieg ist aus ihrer
sicht ganz klar dass hier ganz kurz ja
oder nein was ist das ziel der füchse
militärischer sieg gegen putin gegen die
russischen truppen
der eu außenkommissarin der mit frau von
der leyen in käfer hat das zum ersten
mal offen ausgesprochen hat nämlich
gesagt dieser krieg wird auf dem
schlachtfeld entschieden
und das heißt wir müssen alles tun damit
die ukraine in gewinnt so und davor
scheut die bundesregierung noch zurück
das so klar auszusprechen hersteller
militärischer sieg ist aus ihrer sicht
nicht das ziel oder kann nicht das ziel
sein erste ziel muss sein dass der krieg
aufhört waffenruhe humanitäre hilfen und
natürlich kein diktat frieden aber man
muss auch bedenken wir reden über die
zweitgrößte atommacht der welt und das
sagt sich sehr leicht was hier
formuliert wird ich glaube dass das ganz
schwierig ist dann hat ein elendes blut
opfer zur folge wenn wir über wochen
lang stellungskrieg reden das kann nicht
die richtige antwort sein und ich
bezweifle auch dass militärische logik
oberbeck wie tragen sie sich mit der
frage nach waffenlieferungen wir hören
ein weber der waffen waffen waffen
gehören herren höchster sagt zitiert
herren borel der sagt das wird auf dem
schlachtfeld entschieden wir hören herrn
stegner der sich schwer damit tut und
nach einer waffenruhe ruft wie verhält
sich die katholische kirche in dieser
schwierigen fragen waffen waffen waffen
damit wir putin besiegen
das ist eine auseinandersetzung kommt
das autokratische system auf der anderen
seite nicht erwartet staaten
demokratischer systeme
ich kann auch nur sagen wir müssen für
die bereiche recht hat die demokratische
hauptpunkt sein und das alles tun
innerhalb der kirche ist das relativ
bestritten und fährt und auch
untereinander noch sehr klar und es gibt
diejenigen sagen es muss bis 17 gehen
wir verhandeln kann das ist derjenigen
die sorgen und eindeutig auf die seite
der ukraine geschlagen dann die vielen
die sich um entscheiden darf denn für
mich ist ziemlich klar dass das ganze
ein elektrischer fertig ist und auch
bleibt und angesichts der vielen vielen
vielen formen von verhandlungen dieser
stattgefunden haben sich ganz ohne lügen
die durchsichtige angestellt haben habe
ich dem ganzen nicht mehr wenn ich
ehrlich bin aber auch von mir selber als
militärbischof könnte auch in meinem
gewissen wirklich gefragt in dieser
frage er kann man das verantworten
möglicherweise eine wirkliche
militärischen existieren tricks und das
mit vielen opfern leider frage ich mich
was passiert ihm das nicht und gibt es
genauso viele aufführungen auf der
anderen seite und von daher gesehen
die entscheidung ist also zwischen zwei
schlechten optionen aber wir müssen
diejenigen treffen die auf dauer für
eine freiwillig alle menschen das kostet
viel
eine wichtige frage ist natürlich in
jedem krieg gerade für sie als
militärbischof darf man töten dürfen wir
in diesen momenten töten wie geht ihre
antwort auf die frage die immer wieder
viele zuschauer stellen darf man putin
töten
das alles ist nur dass wir dürfen auf
selbstverteidigung alles tun was uns
schützt als auch menschen die sonst
möglicherweise neben zweite frage diese
stellen nicht die größe des piraten mord
und
[Musik]
an
diesem tag das rechtsfahrgebot sagen
dass man nur als 100 enthalten einen
menschen aktiv auf diesen kulturen zu
wollen dann empfangen die franken einen
ort
[Musik]
ich danke ihnen sehr für diese
diskussion im katholischen
militärbischof franz josef overbeck dem
csu
vizechef der konservativen im parlament
manfred weber ich danke ihnen herr
stegner für die diskussion und ihnen der
für diese debatte zwischen ja moral
gewissen
wirtschaft und immer wieder
waffenlieferungen herzlichen dank dafür
wir sehen uns wieder am nächsten sonntag
um 16 uhr hierbei bild die richtigen
fragen
[Musik]